median which means he's one of the few
people who can understand what exactly
is happening in our intelligence
community
he joins us now adam crawford good to
see you um
you want to make it diverse you go on
shutterstock and you buy a picture of a
blind guy with a dog
does that achieve the objective
well it gets you close but i think we've
even gotten closer because
i blew a call into my agent he knows
some of the people
from that photo and he informed me that
the dog is gay
so well now now they're getting
somewhere
and how does he i'm not even going to
ask how he knows that
but i want you to know that that's what
strength looks like
do you feel safer knowing that our intel
community is represented by stock photos
on
shutterstock of blind men gay dogs and
attractive women in wheelchairs
no because when it comes to the intel
community i want the best
and the brightest not the least widest
that seems fair so why i mean stepping
back three steps
why would you care what your
intelligence analysts for example
look like is that related to job
performance in any way do you think
no it has nothing to do with job
performance obviously but it does make
me
think as i was watching your opening
monologue
those people who know world war ii
history know
that in 1944 the japanese government
sent over incendiary bombs that went
up to the jet stream and they were going
to float over the pacific northwest
and they were going to come down and
they're going to start fires in the
pacific northwest and the idea was
we would have to then fight our own
fires on our own soil and we couldn't
fight them
in the pacific theater and this is
analogous to that
this is us fighting ourself this woke
culture
the diversity the racism cries the
gender
the homophobia this is us fighting
ourselves the russians and the and the
chinese must be delighted
that we've have a self-induced civil war
on our own nation two years
by the way five years after first two
term black president
that we've decided to use the race
hustlers
and start essentially a war on our own
soil so they're
with their homogeneous population china
and russia are just free to use their
technology
to shut down our pipelines and hack into
our
infrastructure while we're using our
technology to photoshop
i mean that you make a really serious
and deeply sad point that i
i know historians will spend their
careers writing about why did this
happen it didn't have to happen
that's kind of what you're saying it's
it seems like at the at the moment where
we kind of proved that the country
was not the country it was say 150 years
ago
we decided to attack ourselves or our
leaders decided to attack our country
why do you think that happened honestly
uh i think it's a combination of
too much time too many people not real
problems
people not working with their hands
people living in a digital world versus
an analog world
and we've become like rich troubled
teenage girls who are just cutting on
our inner thighs now because we don't
have
chores to do i think you're exactly
right
i and i i would say we're not hiring the
best and the brightest it's nothing to
do with diversity it's just low
standards
we got another picture apparently from
the intel community
they just pull stuff off the internet
here it is you can see these are people
they're claiming are currently working
and they pulled a picture of you right
off the internet
you're now yeah
i mean i don't know do you have legal
recourse
here they're saying you work for the cia
i am i'm going to lawyer up as soon as
we
knock off this cross chat and i'm going
to get back with my agent and find out
just
how he knew that dog was gay thank you
text me adam carolla great to see you
tonight
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else